[Musique]
amman il nous montre rien c'est à croire
qu'il n'ya que du vide en toi
[Musique]
pas celle de little rock john hay adams
queen and trade a réussi à nous réserver
une classe de 6 e can find the right one
[Musique]
service de recouvrement de créances
prenez vos affaires personnelles qu'est
ce qui se passait je suis en faillite
je peux pas danser
j'aimerais savoir si je pourrais venir
m'entraîner
quand je bloque sur un truc je tente
autre chose ça dit ok un petit peu de
hip hop 4 5 6
est ce que c'est ça s'appelle un battle
[Musique]
j'ai assisté à la transformation jeté du
passé de danseuse médiocre a dans ce
formidable d'un prof particulier c'est
ça non
il raconté à des amis ce qui se passe
non j'ai rien
je peux savoir ce qui se passe un petit
conseil mon pote éloigne-toi d'elle
sinon pas aussi à capri braqueurs
ok allez c'est pas grave recommencer
non non